[Musique]
j'ai failli être pianiste
je garde de la musique
la passion de l' écoute et de la
construction collective comme en musique
une petite phrase timide pianissimo de
s'enfler et embarquer tout un orchestre
je sais maintenant que noyau de salariés
mobilisés par un projet a le pouvoir
immense de mettre en mouvement un
collectif qui le dépasse avant d'être
des rh il ya quatre ans j'ai associé ce
métier aux règles à la lourdeur au
discours convenu aux portes fermées
après vingt ans passés à la gestion au
marketing à l'animation des réseaux de
vente la direction d'une filiale qui
avait bien pu faire pour mériter une
telle punition ce que j'ignorais c'est
que je m'apprêtais à vivre une
expérience humaine d'une richesse
incroyable et qui allait changer
évidemment très profondément mon regard
sur les mecs et vous savez tous que
l'avenir de la presse pose beaucoup de
questions il faut inventer un nouveau
modèle économique il faut faire évoluer
profondément les métiers il faut
bousculer les fonctionnements l'équipe
mon entreprise comme la vôtre peut-être
a besoin de se transformer très vite
moi j'ai le sentiment que dans ce genre
de situation la façon de faire est
crucial en tant que drh pour faire
bouger les choses
j'ai deux positions possibles je peux
faire du lobbying en interne forcé les
projets auprès de la direction générale
mais quand on est femme
trh
on peut imaginer ce que peut peser son
sa conviction face aux businessmen
opérationnelle qui rapporte le chiffre
d'affaires on peut aussi aller à la
rencontre des clips inventer de nouveaux
espaces de travail des nouvelles
expériences et c'est là que j'ai choisi
de mettre mon énergie c'est vrai je les
vérifier les salariés ont eu un immense
potentiel de créativité
dès lors qu'on les laisse s'exprimer et
qu'on leur fait confiance et des
salariés épanouie c'est aussi du
bénéfice dans mon entreprise
tout le monde travaille beaucoup chez
vous aussi sans doute
tout le monde est très pris lee a
beaucoup de réunions peu de
disponibilité certes c'est sans compter
qu'on a monté une université interne en
mode entreprises apprenantes où tout le
monde est invité et il ya plein de
formats possibles alors il ya des
conférences avec des experts des
entrepreneurs des chercheurs des
enseignants on monte des groupes de
travail de veille des ateliers et puis
aussi on propose des conférences pollen
et des lieux ou des salariés
transmettent et diffusent leurs
expériences dans l'entreprise à d'autres
salariés
et puis aussi on fait des formations des
formations qui sont faits par ces mêmes
salariés à leurs collègues mais des
vrais avec feuille de présence avec un
projet pédagogique et ça c'est bien plus
efficace qu'une formation classique et
en plus c'est au coeur des réalités de
l'entreprise
alors me direz-vous ça coûte cher tout
ça et bien non c'est quasiment zéro
budget ont défini les orientations pour
la programmation
on repère les salariés qui vont
intervenir et ô miracle
à chaque fois tout le monde veut bien le
faire on met en place la logistique on
communique dans l'intranet et on fait
des belles affiches avec le visage des
salariés qui vont participer et ça fait
pas de mal à l'égo et à la réputation et
le monde est vraiment content et un
point d'orgue de l'année universitaire
on montre la journée alors la journée
cette moment où l'entreprise est fermée
au public où les salariés ne sont pas à
leur poste de travail et où tout le
monde se place en mode bouillonnement
collectif je vous disais que tout le
monde travaillait beaucoup
mais à chaque fois que j'ai besoin de
solliciter des salariés sur un sujet qui
leur est cher je n'ai aucun problème
pour travailler avec eux il m'arrive de
sécher sur des accords d'entreprise
au terme de longues séances de
négociation avec les partenaires sociaux
j'ai besoin d'idées neuves et aussi
d'idées qui suscite l'adhésion des
managers je réunis un groupe de travail
j'ai tout de suite vingt personnes ont
des bas pendant deux heures
c'est vif c'est sympa et en général on
trouve des solutions
et tout le monde est content parce que
l'accord est signé et en haut et en bas
de la hiérarchie on a réussi quelque
chose ensemble
une autre expérience aussi qui m'a
beaucoup marqué c'est nous avons noué un
partenariat avec une association d aide
à l'intégration des jeunes qui s'appelle
nos quartiers ont des talents
je voulais monter un événement avec mon
équipe pour intégrer ces jeunes dans
l'entreprise
je présente un projet à l'équipe
ils me disent inquiètes on s'en charge
ils se réunissent en groupe projet il
donne des rôles je leur lâche les
baskets ils se mobilisent pour monter
une journée incroyable qui restera
gravée dans les mémoires de tous ordres
et cerise sur le gâteau on a découvert à
cette occasion une jeune femme à la paye
donc un service administratif qui s'est
révélé un talent de communicante
extraordinaire et que finalement on a
muté dans un service marketing où elle
s'éclate aujourd'hui vous voyez les gens
ils plébiscitent tous ces moments un peu
en dehors de la hiérarchie
traditionnelle
c'est comme si à côté de l'organisation
officielle
il y avait une organisation informelle
celle là avec mon équipe on donne les
coups de pouce on met les gens en
contact et surtout on lâche prise
on laisse faire on fait confiance
on cherche pas à tout maîtriser il y a
trois ans mon président a monté une
académie ça veut dire un espace où on
peut apporter son projet et où on pourra
libérer des ressources pour accompagner
ce projet par exemple stéphane en charge
d'une plateforme numérique pour la
jeunesse avait envie de nouveaux formats
et à l'issue d'une conférence à
l'université il rencontra un collègue
techniciens et ensemble ils montent un
projet il le présente à l'académie des
ressources ont débloqué et voilà la
web-radio pomme d'api qui n'ait comme le
magazine que vous connaissez peut-être
qu'ils s'appellent pomme d'api pour les
petits aujourd'hui cette webradio la 13e
radio en france elle a modernisé la
marque de presse et en plus elle fait
des émules dans d'autres secteurs de la
maison on a aussi une autre expérience
dans le cadre de leur entreprise à
prenantes
c'est un projet qui s'appelle give me
five on avait monté deux jours de
hackaton avec une petite entreprise de
l'économie sociale et solidaire que vous
connaissez peut-être qu'ils s'appellent
simplon qui forme de jeunes développeurs
en décrochage scolaire au numérique
vous serez intégré socialement
à l'issue des deux jours due à caton les
pitchs est présenté à la direction
générale en grande pompe
on n'était pas convaincu il en était pas
donné sauf que les salariés qui ont vécu
l'expérience ont voulu persévérer ce qui
faisait partie du journal quotidien qui
cherchait à rajeunir leur public et ce
qui faisait partie du magazine pour les
jeunes qui cherchait un fil d'actualités
également pour leur public
et voilà la naissance de ce projet give
me five donc à partir de tout ce que je
viens de vous dire j'ai envie de vous
livrer cinq convictions je crois à la
force du collectif dans un monde aussi
complexe
personne ne détient la vérité je crois
que le collectif c'est un lieu de
diversité où on peut se douter on peut
se compléter
où on ose se confronter et c'est à cette
condition qu'on pourra trouver les
nouvelles idées vital pour notre
transformation
je crois aussi qu'il faut manager
autrement il y à des entreprises qui
croit qu'il ne faut plus de managers moi
je dis que si sauf qu'il ne faut pas des
sachants il faut des managers coach des
managers qui lâche la bride le rôle de
chef c'est de libérer les énergies
je crois que l'innovation peut surgir de
partout et de chacun du comptable à la
direction financière aux grands éditeurs
plurimédia d'un grand journaliste
à condition de mettre en place des
espaces de travail protégé ou les
personnes pourront s'exprimer
l'innovation ne se commande pas par un
acte d'autorité
je crois aussi que les entreprises
doivent cultiver le droit à l'erreur
dans un monde aussi incertain on peut
pas prévoir ce qui va nous arriver il
faut donc accepter de se tromper il faut
expérimenter inlassablement rebondir
recommencer et puis enfin alors que tout
semble complètement verrouillé je crois
que j'ai plus que je ne le pensais
comme vous tous des marges de manoeuvre
mon rôle de drh et de trouver les
interstices où naîtront les initiatives
il est aussi de repérer les salariés
ambassadeurs qui nous guideront sur de
nouvelles façons de travailler
et aussi c'est sortir aller chercher des
partenaires extérieurs qui nous aideront
à déplacer notre regard et qui nous
aideront à un vrai inventer l'avenir
donc vous voyez aujourd'hui je m'éclate
plus tôt je savoure chaque jour d'être
embarqué dans un projet d'une richesse
humaine incroyable qui me fait oublier
les facettes les plus austères
évidemment qui reste dans ce métier est
donc en fait de punition je crois qu'on
m'a fait un beau cadeau
merci
[Applaudissements]